what inspires me education I think if
there is a chance if we have a shot as a
republic it's going to be in the
education system we blew it as a
generation and the generation before us
we blew it but if we can get the
education fitness system fixed we might
be able to come out of it I mean my mom
was always saying you stand up for
what's right let the whole world crack
stand for what's right and the truth is
most of the time the world falls on you
and it crushes you but once in a while
you stand up and it falls on you and you
can crack the world and it's all not
going to matter in 50 million years the
only thing that's going to not have
faded is the form with what you live
your life so that advice I mean
sometimes I'm accused of being an
extremist but to me it's almost an
experiment to see what happens if you
just stand up and you don't budge for by
the way there is no intellectual debate
anymore about my claims on Wall Street
that hole all these things have come
true the whole intellectual debates over
there's conferences on Wall Street now
or a year ago when people tried to talk
about this it was academics and Wall
Street guys shouting to pet each other
they just had the same Simplot
conference a few weeks ago and that
whole debates over everybody gets that
were right that we're right on the facts
that the debate is how do you change the
regulations but the whole intellectual
debates but one fact one reporter from a
major newswire who's friendly to me
wrote me and I said when is that story
going to come about oh yeah we have a
thousand stories about how crazy this
guy was where's this story that oh all
these things have turned out to be
pretty much right and she wrote back and
said you don't expect it people know it
but people aren't going to write that
story